اكثر وما يبقي جذوه الثوره مشتعله هو توحد
المحتاجين ولا الشهر الثالث تحت مطلبي
اسقاط النظام واكثر ما يهدد باطفائها هو
اختلاف المعارضين لما ستكون عليه البلاد
بعد السقوط
هذا الوتر بدات مرحله التكتيك الجديده
اصوات من اجهزه الامن وكبار الساسه قعدوا
التقييم وهؤلاء يعلمون جيدا ان الشارع ليس
بيدهم وانهم لن يكونوا بماما في حاله تدعم
النظام لذا يحاولون استماره العمائم
المتشدده لفكرتين الاولى الا حل دون اصلاح
بنيه النظام والثانيه ان الفجوه ستتعمق
اذا تم تبني خطوه تجميليه لعمليه المعالجه
وهو ملفات اليه رئيس مجلس الشورى محمد
فكره متاخره والوصفه اللي صحيفه مستقل
وبين هاتين الفكرتين في ثالثه مبادره
تعيني ابراهيم رئيسي على راس القضاء لكن
هل هي فعلا خطوه حقيقيه لمحاربه الفساد
كما يروج لها الاصلاحين ام انها جرعته امل
بعمر الافتراضيا قصيرا جدا تفسير لا يزال
غير واضح لكن اكيد ان كبسوله الى نقطه
النهايه في الاحتجاجات هو عين الاجتهاد
المطلوب الان وهناك من توصل لضروره خلقا
من سياسيه من اطياف جديده بما يضمن تشتيت
اصوات النزعه الانفصاليه خصوصا في المناطق
الكرديه
فوجهاء محافظه كردستان تجرا على طلب
استفتاء على مشروعيه النظام واهل بلوشستان
مستمرون بالمطالبه بحقوقهم رغم استشراس
الامن والاضطرابات في كراج تنتقل الى
طيران وتخترق الحواجز العرقيه والطائفيه
رفراندومي باسا ذكر اجراء مقبوله مردود
ومع حضور معتمدان وراهبران الديني وميلي
واهمشي